allaguis treffer jetzt rede ich über
corona corona leider nicht nur eine
schlimme krankheit sondern die ausrede
für alles unser aufgeblasener xxl
bundestag schafft es wohl wieder nicht
eine wahlrechtsreform hinzukriegen das
problem ist seit jahren bekannt aber
jetzt mit corona sorry
was willst du machen da bauen wir lieber
noch einen zweiten reicht hat oben drauf
weil wir mit corona beschäftigt sind
glauben politiker sie kommen mit allem
durch julia klöckner zum beispiel koch
bei bild tv mit johann lafer präsentiert
vom sponsor kaufland buchen sie jetzt
bei kaufland unser julchen sie eröffnet
baumärkte und moderiert ihre
silberhochzeit oder hausschlachtung
gates hat die gar nichts gelernt aus der
nächste blamage und dann rutschen sie
mit dem lama auch noch buletten aus
rinder albums am 1 haltungsform 1 das
sind für die gini die sonne gesehen
haben und am ende mit einem trecker
überfahren werden hat sie nicht immer
gesagt die verbraucher müssten erkennen
können und zwar auf den ersten blick
erkennen können ob dort dem was sie
kaufen in ihrer nahrungsmittel mehr tier
wohl drin steckt genau und wenn man dann
liest haltungsform 1 dann sagt man zum
allen lafer steck dir deinen
geschredderten hindernis sonst wohin ich
geh nach hause
peinlich
sogar gerichtsverfahren stärken in
diesen tagen am virus selbst wenn
juristisch nichts hängen bleibt an den
dfb-präsidenten niersbach und zwanziger
sowie am ex generalsekretär schmitt im
schweizerischen bellinzona geht das
verfahren ohne urteil zu ende
die vorwürfe sind verjährt offiziell
auch wegen der korona pandemie natürlich
wegen corona wir scheißen jetzt das
alles ist jako o na na da mache ich doch
mit zähneputzen wozu miete zahlen lag
mich endlich wieder im stehen pinkeln
wie gekommen hose tragen in der
öffentlichkeit muss man nicht wie aber
die aka rona diese sinnlose scheue reh
wurde ihnen präsentiert von kaufland
nein wurde sie nicht schlecht ja
it-service bruns weiß ich spreche mit
irgendwie kann ich ihnen weiterhelfen
ja haben immer versucht das gerät aus
und wieder einzuschalten hat nichts
gebracht verstehe
probieren sie doch mal den kanal der
heute show auf youtube zu abonnieren
genau und im zweifel ruhig auch mal den
gefällt mir -button klicken
genau ja ich bleibe in der leitung